bonjour et bienvenue au forum Radio Ici
donc vous êtes invité François
baillereau bonjour bonjour guère en
Ukraine crise de l'énergie Angers
climatique inflation record incertitude
économique comment dans un contexte
aussi incertain rassurer les Français
répondent à leurs écritures en matière
de pouvoir d'achat et puis aussi
préserver le modèle français la droite
réclame des économies la gauche veut
accélérer chez les super profits comment
faire adopter le budget 2023 sans passer
par le 49 fois et puis au-delà quid des
réformes à venir notamment c'est des
retraites mais pour commencer François
Bayrou l'Ukraine l'actualité en Ukraine
de cette guerre de Poutine en Ukraine
est-ce que l'explosion sur le pont de
Crimée symbole du rattachement de la
Russie à l'Ukraine à la Crimée pardon
change la donne est-ce que cela peut
avoir une influence sur la suite du
conflit
à ce qu'on est en train de vivre
d'abord personne ne l'aurait prévu il y
a encore 6 mois
cette espèce de basculement
de l'idée d'une armée surpuissante
une des plus puissantes armées de terre
de la planète
s'attaquant à un pays de taille moyenne
pour l'annexer
et puis voir la résistance se constituée
autour de l'idée nationale la première
fois depuis longtemps en Ukraine et puis
voir que cette résistance elle finit par
avancer elle finit par renverser le
rapport de force découvrir les
faiblesses de l'armée russe tout ça est
un est un basculement est-ce que c'est
un avantage
qui va se qui va se révéler
tout à fait important pour l'Ukraine
est-ce que l'Ukraine peut gagner la
guerre est-ce que Poutine peut perdre sa
gueule je répète poser la question
aujourd'hui en octobre 2022 en ces
termes si on avait entendu ça il y a
encore 6 ou 7 mois ça aurait été
considéré comme
rêverie
oui quelque chose se passe qui est très
important qui sera étudié je n'en doute
pas dans toutes les académies militaires
stratégiques
quelque chose à profondément changé et
les images qu'on découvre et les
décisions que Poutine prend vous avez vu
qu'il a changé le chef d'état-major en
tout cas le responsable militaire de
cette de cette attaque de cette
opération comme ils disent
quelque chose est en train de changer
et ce qui apparaît aujourd'hui
sur chaque page que l'on tourne et que
l'on lit ce qui apparaît ce sont les
faiblesses Russes et les faiblesses de
les faiblesses d'image qu'on ne pensait
pas revoir qui ont 50 60 70 80 ans avec
les soldats russes dont on s'aperçoit
qu'ils n'ont pas les équipements
minimaux les chaussures les chaussettes
enfin tout ce qui fait tout ce qui fait
qu'une armée peut agir peut se montrer
forte il n'y a pas cette guerre de
légitimité y compris j'en suis sûr aux
yeux des soldats russes et aux yeux des
officiers russes il y a pas de
légitimité en revanche aux yeux des
parents qui perdent leurs enfants bien
sûr et en vend en revanche ces constitué
cette armée le patriotisme ukrainien et
la volonté ukrainienne de retrouver la
souveraineté alors deux trois questions
toujours sur le sur l'Ukraine sur la
guerre du crâne est-ce qu'il faut
prendre au sérieux les menaces
nucléaires de Poutine est-ce que pour
vous
juste un barbare un dictateur quelqu'un
avec il faut négocier ou quelqu'un qu'il
faut mettre au banc des nations est-ce
que c'est un régime qu'il faut
contribuer à faire tomber alors est-ce
qu'il faut prendre au sérieux les
menaces de Poutine oui il faut prendre
au sérieux les menaces on a vu à quel
point Poutine en articulant des menaces
contre la souveraineté ukrainienne alors
que de des esprits nombreux disaient
jamais il n'attaquera vous dit que vous
vous
n'y pensez pas ça n'est même pas
envisageable et vous voyez les visages
en France y compris
de ce dans le débat non jamais je puis
attester que jamais le président de la
République n'a pensé qu'il n'attaquerait
pas il a toujours pensé que c'était un
risque mais vous connaissez les leaders
nombreux on va parler de Mélenchon à
Zemmour qui ont annoncé
Urby et Orbit qu'il n'y aurait aucune
attaque que ça n'était même pas
envisageable c'était de la propagande
américaine est-ce que elle est
est-ce qu'il faut contribuer à faire
tomber le régime de Poutine
l'Europe et la France ne vont pas
s'immiscer dans les affaires intérieures
de la Russie mais vous voyez bien qu'un
tyran qui déclenche une guerre pour
conquérir le pays voisin et qui se fait
repousser non seulement repoussé mais à
bien des milliers à bien des égards
humiliés dans cette confrontation
celui-là se retrouve extrêmement fragile
aux yeux de ses propres partisans et
c'est toujours de l'intérieur que
viennent les déstabilisations c'est pas
de l'extérieur je pense que une
affirmée que on devrait envisager des
opérations extérieures ce serait une
très grave imprudence contre-productive
y compris pour tous ceux en Russie qui
se disent que Poutine ça n'est pas
l'avenir de la Russie et qu'il les a
entraînés dans une aventure qu'ils vont
payer très très cher le prix Nobel de la
paix pour ces trois organisations
pour la paix c'est ainsi
non mais c'est ainsi vous parlez de la
France
en France le camp robotique ne faiblit
pas à l'extrême droite mais aussi elle
est fait à travers une position à la
géométrie variable de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
un jour qui accuse l'automne un autre
jour Poutine et puis le suivant zelinsky
puis aussi c'est royal que vous
connaissez bien qui est mis en doute
certains crimes de guerre de la Russie
en Ukraine qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
est-ce qu'il y a une cinquième colonne
proposée en France moi je dirais pas les
choses comme ça il y a
traditionnellement en France
une vision
historiquement fondée
et que je ne rejette pas qui est de dire
que la Russie est un partenaire de
l'Union européenne et la Russie est pour
la France un partenaire historique nous
avons avec la Russie partagée
bien des enjeux historiques au travers
du Millénaire qui vient de s'écouler
donc
bien sûr que la est à bien des égards
européennes et bien sûr qu'un jour on
peut espérer que
de nouvelles autorités russes seront
pour les autorités européennes et
singulièrement pour les autorités
françaises des partenaires avec qui on
pourra faire quelque chose
confondre cette
cette ce destin historique et cet
obligation de de respect des liens
historiques avec Poutine alors c'est ne
pas comprendre et ne pas voir que
Poutine est un dévoiement que Poutine
est pour la Russie aura été pour la
Russie ces dernières années un malheur
épouvantable parce que tout d'un coup à
la fois il a révélé les faiblesses et il
a mis son pays dans une situation
d'extrême fragilité ce qui est le lot
des tyrans assez souvent quand où le
plus souvent ou même toujours lorsque
sont entraînés par ce que les Grecs
appelaient ubris c'est-à-dire ne plus
voir la réalité et ne plus imaginer le
monde qu'au travers de sa propre gloire
peut-être lubrifi aussi en Iran qu'elle
regarde vous portez sur la situation
d'Iran sur ses femmes qui au périls de
leur vie se révolent contre le port du
voile et contre les régimes islamiste je
trouve qu'il y a peu d'images aussi
émouvantes aussi significative que celle
que nous découvrons avec cette révolte
des jeunes femmes qui brandissent leur
voile enlever comme étendard de liberté
je trouve que nous sommes profondément
impliqué avec elle et
s'agissant des femmes iraniennes je
n'oublie pas non plus les femmes afghane
qui elles sont encore dans leur prison
les femmes les jeunes femmes
les jeunes filles et les petites filles
qui sont empêchées de sortir de faire
des études par des régimes
fanatiques et
dont le fanatisme est barbare
et aussi bien que l'Afghanistan et que
d'autres pays d'ailleurs oui je parle
oui mais enfin ces deux pays là sont
toujours dit en première ligne et les
femmes iraniennes nous donnent le son de
courage incroyable parce que elle
sortent en sachant qu'on peut les tuer
en sachant que le régime peut les tuer
mais elles disent si on sort assez
nombreuses le régime sera pas assez fort
pour basculer toutes et alors quand vous
constatez qu'en Iran ces femmes se
battent jusqu'à en payer de leur vie
pour avoir le droit de pas de ne pas
porter le voile et qu'en France le port
du voile est devenu une revendication
des islamistes mais aussi d'un certain
nombre de militants féministes voire de
parties de gauche qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire
vous savez c'est c'est moi qui est
interdit le voile à l'école quand vous
étiez une liste d'éducation
j'ai absolument le souvenir des
polémiques qu'il y a eu sur ce sujet
simplement
vous voyez bien de quoi ça c'est 1984
vous voyez bien de quoi il s'agissait
c'était
un étendard pour affirmer que la loi de
la religion était plus importante que la
loi du pays
et on a réussi c'est drôle d'ailleurs
parce que une des jeunes femmes qui m'a
aidé à être médiatrice sur ces histoires
de voile c'est Rachida Dati c'était la
première responsabilité qu'elle assumée
elle le rappelle toujours d'ailleurs
avec émotion et donc cette cette
ce combat là entre
ceux qui veulent que la loi de la
religion soit plus importante que toutes
les autres lois et ceux qui au contraire
défendent notamment à l'école la loi la
loi
la loi des institutions et les valeurs
de la République supérieure à tout autre
valeur qu'on peut personnellement
adopter évidemment
cette aujourd'hui d'actualité aussi et
voir le combat des femmes en Iran je
suis persuadé que ça ça trouble
profondément un certain nombre de celles
qui sont engagées dans ce dans ce
dilemme là puisque vous parlez de ce qui
se passe à l'école on va préciser les
choses il y a une énième offensive des
mouvements prairies ces salafistes pour
déstabiliser les codes publics en
incitant les élèves via les réseaux
sociaux notamment apporter des vêtements
religieux imposés un certain nombre de
pratiques cultuelles au sein des
établissements scolaires prière jeunes
collectif chantage envers les élèves
considérés comme non conformes justement
vous avez été mise d'éducation nationale
vous avez aussi été professeur
est-ce qu'il faut prendre cette
offensive au sérieux et comment il faut
il faut y répondre alors je faut faire
très attention à ne pas créer des
problèmes
affirmant qu'on va les résoudre
il faut les constater en tout cas
l'ouverture de de front successifs c'est
aussi une manière de constamment crisper
les rapports à l'intérieur du pays donc
moi je pense que en tout cas ces
offensives dont vous parlez pour
l'instant n'ont pas la portée qui
devrait en faire un débat national trois
ans après l'assassinat de Samuel Paty
l'école est en danger la laïcité est en
danger ou pas
laïcité est en danger tous les jours
et le drame qu'on a vécu avec
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty et le et ce
qui a été l'émotion intense la vague
d'émotion de la nation
y compris avec le très beau discours du
président de la République tout ça tout
ça a contribué à faire un barrage de
plus aux attaques contre la laïcité je
pense que
pour nous
qui sommes citoyens républicains
démocrate et républicains
cette c'est une ligne de partage
nous avons vécu ce jour-là
jusqu'où pouvait mener
le drame le fanatisme et l'absurdité et
je pense que ça
conduit à la vous voyez bien nous sommes
dans une société
qui à tous les tournants de la route se
trouve menacé d'être jeté dans le fossé
des détestations Eden
et c'est un but en soi
qu'il y ait des courants philosophiques
et politiques qui disent nous ne nous
laisserons pas entraîner dans ce
chemin-là
il se trouve cependant que dans la
nature humaine il y a ça et donc la
vigilance armée moralement armée le
réarmement moral en face de ce genre de
risque et de pente et quelque chose dont
nous avons vous et nous comme citoyens
la responsabilité
je voulais qu'on parle aussi de la
d'Arménie le 13 septembre dernier
l'Azerbaïdjan dans une nouvelle
offensive armée contre la République
d'Arménie envahissant son territoire et
bombardant des populations civiles face
à cette agression puisqu'il s'agit d'une
agression comment la France peut-elle et
comment la France doit-elle s'engager
aux côtés de l'Arménie
est-ce que devrait s'engager d'abord en
étant lucide ce que vous dites
Azerbaïdjan c'est la Turquie qui est
derrière cette
sensible a été à l'origine du premier
génocide du génocide
qui est reconnu par la loi en France
la France a avec l'Arménie des liens
indéfectibles
c'est l'histoire et c'est pas seulement
l'histoire c'est la présence de la
sensibilité arménienne dans la société
française
c'est l'heure leur présence leur
vibration si je puis employer des mots
comme ça qui sont infiniment précieuses
pas seulement pour l'Arménie le souvenir
arménien mais pour notre réalité de
nationale pour la France pour les
valeurs de la République leur engagement
pour la France et notre engagement pour
l'amitié avec la momie pas seulement
l'amitié le la solidarité l'irréductible
engagement pour que on n'efface pas ce
que leur histoire tragique a été
donc l'Arménie est-ce que la force
devrait faire plus bah je pense qu'elle
fait absolument tout ce qu'elle peut
alors retour en France aux questions
franco-françaises au débat
franco-française avec le début du débat
budgétaire demain au Parlement la droite
réclame des économies la gauche veut
accélérer chez les super profits est-ce
que la majorité doit céder est-ce que le
49-3 est inévitable pour faire adopter
le budget pas le 49-3 c'est une arme
institutionnelle classique
tous ceux qui disent que que le 49.3 est
un abus sont à côté de la plaque
pour tout oui y compris pour les
retraites
le
49-3 est une arme
institutionnelle
que les gouvernements ont à leur
disposition
lorsqu'ils n'ont pas de majorité
et qu'ils savent cependant que dans les
oppositions il n'y aura pas d'accord
pour renverser le gouvernement
et donc pour aller à de nouvelles
élections parce que c'est automatique le
lien entre les deux en 5e République est
automatique et donc c'est une arme
institutionnelle et je ne sais qu'ici ou
là on dit que c'est pas possible que
c'est un abus que c'est trop que depuis
des dizaines d'années
j'ai le souvenir que Michel Rocard avait
utilisé des dizaines de fois
maintenant on peut plus et donc et donc
sauf pour les textes
pour les textes budgétaires et donc
c'est une arme j'ai d'ailleurs jamais
compris pourquoi on l'avait limité je
n'ai pas voté cette réforme
pour deux ou trois raisons mais celle-là
en était une et donc
le 49-3 oui bien sûr on peut l'utiliser
dès la semaine prochaine afin de la
semaine prochaine vous confirmez non je
pense que le gouvernement et la majorité
vont faire tout ce qu'ils se trouve pour
trouver le plus d'accord possible pour
démontrer aux Français parce que ce qui
compte dans cette affaire c'est pas les
partis politiques c'est ce que c'est pas
les oppositions c'est pas les groupes
politiques à l'Assemblée ce sont les
Français qui sont
de l'autre côté de l'écran de télévision
qui sont les vrais juges de ce qui se
passe et notamment les vrais juges d'une
question qui est essentielle et qu'on va
retrouver je suis sûr dans la suite de
cet entretien c'est la bonne foi
est-ce que les Français entendent des
sentent que de la part des gouvernants
il y a une démarche de bonne foi que ça
veut dire débattre avec les oppositions
autour du budget
et ne pas stopper le débat budgétaire
tout de suite c'est à dire la semaine
prochaine je pense que il y a
du bon à trouver dans la recherche d'un
certain nombre de constats qui peuvent
réunir ceux qui sont aux prises dans
l'hémicycle alors bonne fois et au-delà
et au-delà bonne fois Édouard Philippe
s'exprime qui s'exprime aujourd'hui dans
Le Parisien considère qu'il faut faire
davantage pour réduire la dette publique
et de vous comme lui inquiet concernant
la maîtrise de la dette commande ne
serait-ce pas
je me suis battu toute ma vie sur ce
sujet là
simplement on a été dans une situation
qui était une situation plus
plus
accommodante
parce que on a vécu pendant une grande
période avec de l'argent à 0% et avec
l'injonction de sauver les familles et
les entreprises notre économie et notre
vie sociale parce que le covid pouvait
tout d'un coup nous dans une crise
énorme et là hélas nous sommes entrés
dans une période d'inflation et on a
oublié en France depuis très longtemps
ce que l'inflation pouvait être on l'a
oublié depuis le milieu des années 70
et on découvre aujourd'hui à quel point
l'inflation
à quel point
à quel point l'inflation est une course
en avant qui fait une surenchère
perpétuelle et donc
un poison pour un certain nombre de
Français un poison tout le monde le sait
pour les épargnants mais c'est pas ça
n'est pas l'essentiel un poison parce
que c'est une c'est une c'est un orage
qui
crée une instabilité complète une bombe
à fragmentation une instabilité complète
pour tous les décideurs économiques
quand vous êtes le problème de
l'augmentation des salaires ou pas quand
vous êtes un décideur économique
qu'est-ce qui vous fait
une décision d'investissement par
exemple ou
d'augmentation qu'est-ce qui vous ou de
créer un nouveau produit qu'est-ce qui
vous fait prendre cette décision c'est
ce que les économistes appellent les
anticipations vous vous dites est-ce que
demain ça va aller mieux qu'aujourd'hui
donc si l'activité augmente si
j'investige je vais gagner de l'argent
et là on sait plus et là on ne sait plus
et l'incertitude et le pire ennemi des
décisions économiques et d'une économie
puissante incertitude peut-être aussi au
niveau des retraites Édouard Philippe
toujours lui affirme dans Le Parisien va
exhorte dans Le Parisien le gouvernement
a bougé beaucoup sur les retraites il
affirme aussi qu'il est favorable au
report de l'âge légal entre 65 et 67 ans
comme c'est le cas en Allemagne et en
Italie est-ce que c'est un ballon
d'essai pour le compte de d'Emmanuel
Macron non non
pas que je sache comme vous voyez bien
il y a des attitudes différentes dans la
majorité
indiquer les les différences les
divergences ou les nuances que j'avais
sur ce sujet là je pense que
65 je pense que la question des
retraites n'est pas une question
uniquement budgétaire la question des
retraites c'est un projet de société
tous ceux qui sont au travail ont une
idée de la retraite elle peut être
différente par exemple il y a des gens
qui sont en pleine forme il y a des
familles recomposées il y a des jeunes
enfants
il y a beaucoup de gens femmes et hommes
qui se sentent en pleine forme et ayant
ces charges là
ont l'envie de continuer à travailler il
rencontre assez souvent un problème
c'est que les entreprises ne gardent pas
les seniors ceux qui sont le plus
avancés en âge parce qu'il coûte plus
cher que de plus jeunes et je pense que
ça c'est une question Olivier du socle
la pose dans une interview
et il est il est très juste de poser
cette question il y a des gens qui sont
usés il y a des femmes et des hommes qui
sont usés je ne sais pas notamment de la
pénibilité je ne quitte jamais de la
pensée je suis comme vous savez maire de
peau et
comme la peau comme dans toutes les
villes importantes il y a ce qu'on
appelle un CCAS c'est-à-dire un comité
d'actions sociales qui s'occupe de la
prise en charge de tous les gens qui ont
de graves difficultés je sais ce que
c'est la vie de
j'allais dire de ces femmes et de ses
hommes c'est plus souvent des femmes de
ces femmes qui ont la charge du soin à
ceux qui sont dépendants grabataires
qu'il faut lever c'est très ce sont des
personnes assez souvent lourdes pour des
constitutions frêles de la part de celle
qu'il est qui les aide et moi je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse mettre une norme
unique sur des situations différentes je
pense qu'il veut dire je pense très
important je pense qu'il est très
important de mettre sur la question des
retraites
naturellement une incitation à
travailler plus longtemps incitation et
des incitations
favorables positives
ressenti comme tel par exemple je pense
j'ai avancé l'idée vous savez ça que on
pourrait encourager les gens à
travailler plus longtemps
si on leur donnait pendant qu'il
travaille les dernières les années qu'il
décide de si on leur donnait ou si on
leur verset une partie de leur retraite
10% par exemple de la retraite ou 15%.
ça pourrait changer beaucoup de choses
parce que
récompenser mais il faut changer la
psychologie des entreprises il faut
considérer que ça n'est pas parce que
quelqu'un a plus de 60 ans mettons qu'il
est une charge
ça devrait être un atout et en
particulier pour cette question de la
transmission
de la transition des savoir-faire de la
transmission de l'état d'esprit et un
lien entre entre les jeunes je reviens à
ce que je vous la question que je vous
posais au préalable Édouard Philippe en
parlant de départ à la retraite de 65 à
67 ans ce qui met de l'huile sur le feu
est-ce qu'il met la réforme en danger
comme ça avait été le cas en 2020 quand
il était premier ministre c'est sa
conviction donc moi je je mets du sur le
feu je ne partage pas cette idée que le
seul avenir des retraites ça soit
d'exporter l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 67 ans je ne le crois pas
même si Édouard Philippe dit mais les
Allemands l'ont fait ou les Italiens
l'ont fait encore faudrait-il vérifier
ce qu'est la réalité
sociale que ces décisions ont fait on
fait prendre mais moi je pense au
contraire que plus on met de souplesse
à condition d'obtenir l'objectif de plus
grand nombre de seniors au travail c'est
à dire d'un allongement réel du temps de
travail moyen plus on met de souplesse
et mieux c'est mais et moins c'est
rejeté parce que chacun tout d'un coup
se sent libre par rapport à ce
qu'autrement il pourrait ressentir comme
une contrainte excessive il y a quelques
instants c'est pas un ballon d'essai
pour le compte de Macron
ce qu'il conçoit que comment il conçoit
la réforme des retraites je suppose
est-ce que est-ce que Emmanuel Macron
peut aller dans le sens une retraite des
par la retraite à 67 ans où est-ce que
ça le fait que son ancien Premier se dit
ça ça l'embarrasse quelque part je suis
persuadé que ça n'est pas son idée
vous savez que il a dit pendant la
campagne électorale qu'il était souple
sur cette affaire de l'âge 65 ans non il
a parlé il a parlé d'abord de 65 après
de 70 ans et 2031 et donc je suis
persuadé que ce n'est pas son idée en
tout cas ça n'est pas la mienne
je pense vous savez que je me je me suis
battu pour la retraite par point dès les
élections présidentielles de 2002 et
donc parce que je pense que c'est ça
l'avenir alors il faut revenir à la
retraitement parce que ne me faites pas
dire ce que je dis pas parce que le
le sujet est assez délicat en ce moment
et je n'ai pas l'intention moi de mettre
de l'huile sur le feu je pense
ceci qui est très qui est très précis je
pense que il faut une part ou une
garantie que des situations différentes
obtiendront un traitement différent et
que une c'est une décision si importante
pour la vie qu'il faut qu'on garantisse
que le choix de ceux qui vont partir à
la retraite d'une certaine manière aura
sa place dans la décision de ce départ
et ça c'est quelque part un message que
lance le haut-commissaire au plan le
secrétaire général de
terminer la question le secrétaire
général du Conseil national de la
refondation à Laurent Berger
il faut le s'agit pas de
s'agit pas de connivence il faut le
remettre au sein du dispositif je vais
vous dire une chose simple
quels sont les quels sont les atouts du
pays dans la situation si difficile nous
nous trouvons et dans la crise si
menaçante qui est devant nous vous savez
que j'ai dit il y a déjà plusieurs mois
que c'était pour moi la crise la plus
grave depuis la guerre
dans laquelle on n'y est pas entré dans
laquelle nous allons entrer vraiment
donc je suis très très prudent sur cette
affaire quels sont les atouts que la
société française a en son sein pour moi
la toux principal c'est le grand courant
réformiste du pays donc notamment
c'est-à-dire
ceux qui dans le monde politique dans le
monde syndical dans le monde associatif
considère que ça n'est pas la violence
que ça n'est pas le renversement de nos
cadres de vie qui sont la solution pour
l'avenir
tous ceux qui pensent qu'il faut faire
évoluer les choses dans le sens de plus
de d'attention aux difficultés et dans
le sens de plus d'ambition pour produire
pour imaginer pour former pour éduquer
c'est cela qui sont les vrais alliés de
la société française et des plus
fragiles dans la société française et
dans ces cours-là il y a évidemment le
syndicalisme réformiste il y a les
courants politiques réformés si elle est
courant associatifs réformés peut te
raccrocher à cette réforme ou pas oui
bah vous lui poserez la question vous
voyez bien le le
l'idée qu'on s'exprime toujours à la
place des autres alors vous n'êtes pas
mon idée mais j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour Laurent Berger et j'ai beaucoup
d'espoir dans la prise de conscience de
ce courant qui est pour moi un courant
central pour l'avenir du pays un
référendum sur la réforme des retraites
j'ai toujours défendu ce principe mais
là aujourd'hui vous l'aurez aujourd'hui
je ne je ne me prononce pas sur ce point
je trouve que Olivier du soft fait du
bon travail et je voudrais simplement
dire une chose si vous permettez
comme vous savez je me suis beaucoup
battu pour connaître cette période de
concertation
et donc je je crois beaucoup à la
nécessité
de prendre le temps de préciser
et notamment aux yeux de l'opinion
publique
les raisons qui rendent indispensables
la réforme des retraites alors au départ
attendez j'ai pas tout à fait fini
je pense que une grande partie des
Français
à l'esprit qui faut une réforme des
retraites ils savent pas très bien
pourquoi sauf qu'il voit bien autour
d'eux que il y a un vieillissement un
allongement de la durée de la vie et de
la durée de la vie en bonne santé et que
cet allongement il entraîne une chose
c'est que la charge des pensions de
retraite elle pèse sur ce qui travaille
c'est ça la retraite par répartition
c'est à dire
tous ceux qui sont au travail payent la
pension de ceux qui sont en retraite or
comme il y a de plus en plus de gens à
la retraite et de moins en moins de gens
au travail en tout cas de violence
proportionnellement évidemment les
Français pensent que oui c'est
raisonnable mais personne ne donne
jamais les chiffres personne ne donne
jamais des faits établis
pose sur la table y compris le corps et
quand soumette à la discussion le corps
qui est une instance sûrement de bonne
foi ils sont assez évolutifs dans leur
c'est le moins qu'on en puisse dire donc
les gens il faut qu'on avance dans mais
il faut qu'on avance et je vous
encourage à réfléchir à ça il faut
avancer non pas seulement dans les
négociations entre organisation et
gouvernement faut avancer dans la prise
de conscience de l'opinion publique et
c'est pour moi probablement l'enjeu le
plus important de ces trois mois de
concertation vous a senti isolé au sein
de majorité quand vous avez mis en garde
justement quand un passage en force de
la réforme des retraites notamment via
le PLFSS c'est le 49-3 un projet de loi
en bonne et due forme sera finalement
présenté début 2023 afin d'essai du
temps à la concurrusez-moi est-ce que
est-ce qu'on peut corriger votre
affirmation et vous dites on vous a
senti isolé mais c'est ma thèse qui a
été retenue la fin de la question est-ce
que vous considérez que vous avez gagné
c'est parti non je ne je ne je place
jamais les choses dans des questions de
rapport de force et de bras de fer je
lorsque je considère qu'un problème est
essentiel je m'exprime publiquement pour
que puisse se constituer une réflexion
commune je suis
radicalement je sais pas comment on peut
dire
attaché à une idée simple c'est que nous
sommes co-responsables de l'avenir
jamais pensé ou jamais accepter l'idée
qu'il y avait des gens qui étaient au
pouvoir que c'était eux qui étaient les
patrons et les responsables et que de
notre côté il y avait
des Français qui sont qui seraient en
fait des sujets j'ai jamais accepté
cette idée l'idée qui est la mienne
c'est que nous sommes tous citoyens
c'est-à-dire tous responsables de
l'avenir que nous soyons dans la
majorité dans l'opposition ou ne sachant
si on est où on se trouve dans ces
affrontements là nous sommes
co-responsables et cette
correspondabilité là je suis pour qu'on
l'exerce alors je l'exerce comme un
citoyen qui a des responsabilités
politiques je l'exerce comme un citoyen
qui s'exprime je l'exerce comme
responsable des institutions se confie
par exemple le Commissariat aux plans je
l'exerce quand on me demande de
enfin d'être de ceux qui animent le
conseil de la refondation de la
refondation je les exerce tout à l'heure
et comme élu locale alors il faut que je
paye il reste pas beaucoup de temps il
reste une dizaine de minutes plein de
questions donc j'essaie de vous poser
des questions courtes essayer de faire
des réponses courtes on a parlé très
doué et peut-être je préfère des
réponses un peu plus longues
alors on a on a parlé de Laurent Berger
à l'instant le leader de la CFDT donc le
grand berger désapprouve la grève dit-il
préventive lancée par la CGT dans la
raffinerie si les grèves se
poursuivaient dans les raffineries
notamment chez Total
Erickson mobile est-ce qu'il faudra
envisager le retour la force publique et
est-ce qu'il faudrait envisager le
recours à les réquisitions pour éviter
une pénurie de carburant alors je crois
qu'il y a une très grande émotion chez
les Français et que c'est une émotion
qui on dit avoir des
salariés d'entreprises qui par ailleurs
sont en très bonne santé financière
user de cette épreuve de la grève comme
vous dites préventive pour obtenir des
avantages sociaux
le pays est
suffisamment grande difficulté pour que
chacun
fasse face à ses responsabilités et que
réfléchissent en conscience et si ça
n'était pas le cas si on était devant
des situations d'irresponsabilités alors
le gouvernement serait fondé à prendre
les mesures plus drastiques que vous
avez
combien de temps on a combien de temps
le gouvernement combien de temps qui est
bien c'est que c'est que quand on est
journaliste on peut poser des questions
même quand on est positionnée
une question de gens Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il appelle une grande marche contre la
vie chère dimanche prochain 16 octobre
et puis la comparé ça marche ça marche
avec la Révolution française je cite son
tweet du de jeudi dernier le 5 et 6
octobre 1789 les femmes marchent sur
Versailles contre la vie chère elle
ramène le roi la reine et le dauphin de
force à Paris sous contrôle populaire
faites mieux le 16 octobre
en gros c'est un appel à la violence à
couper des têtes tout c'est dangereux
c'est délicieux aujourd'hui pousse à la
radicalisation à la violence à la mise
en accusation à l'injure y compris à des
violences physiques tout cela pour moi
et contraire à l'Internet national
Mélenchon il devient factieux silicieux
non je veux pas utiliser des mots de cet
ordre
vous voyez bien de quoi il s'agit
on a une société qui est en très grande
tension la France est en très grande
tension et vous avez deux sortes de
d'attitude il y a ceux qui passent leur
temps à mettre de l'huile sur le feu à
verser de l'essence sur les braises
parce qu'il pense que c'est dans ces
affrontements et dans ces violences et
dans la dureté de ces luttes que se
trouve un avenir quelconque et puis il y
a ceux
dont je suis qui pense que une une
société ne peut pas se conduire dans
l'explosion permanente dans les
affrontements de tous les instants dans
les injures regardez ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée nationale franchement vous
avez été responsable de la chaîne de
l'Assemblée nationale moi je voudrais
que les médias retransmettent la réalité
des débats aujourd'hui il faut que tous
ceux qui écoutent sachent ceux qui
dans l'hémicycle qu'est-ce qui se passe
les médias couplent les micros de
l'hémicycle de manière qu'on entend de
pas les injures les hurlements et les
accusations donc faudrait que si on les
entendait les Français seraient indignés
de la manière dont on profite de leur
vote pour pour dévoyer leurs sentiments
politiques et je trouve que c'est
vraiment aller à l'encontre de l'idée de
la démocratie représente il faut pas
mettre d'huile sur le feu il y a un
projet et un sur l'immigration qui va
avoir lieu à assemblée Emmanuel Macron a
annoncé un projet de loi sur
l'immigration et sur l'asile sur l'asile
début 2023 est-ce que c'est de mettre de
l'huile sur le feu de proposer comme il
l'a dit d'installer des migrants à la
campagne en tout cas je pense que je
pense que cette expression peut être
utilisée dans un mauvais sens donc cette
expression du président de la République
et donc moi ce que je pense sur
l'immigration la première chose pourquoi
est-ce que les lois successives que nous
votons ne marche pas ne sont pas mises
en application avant de voter de
nouvelles lois je rêve d'une république
qui se dirait qu'elle doit d'abord faire
marcher les lois qu'elle a déjà votées
et qui en effet ne sont pas appliqués et
pourquoi en particulier y a-t-il un
certain nombre de pays qui refusent de
reprendre leur ressortissants lorsqu'ils
sont en situation irrégulière
on a fait déjà des progrès sur la
rapidité de traitement des dossiers mais
ça ne suffit pas donc ça c'est donc ça
c'est la première chose deuxièmement la
question qui au fond est derrière ces
affirmations c'est la question de
l'intégration et pour moi la question de
l'intégration elle se pose très
précisément sur deux sujets le premier
sujet c'est la langue française
c'est-à-dire aussi
l'apprentissage des mœurs des coutumes
de la manière de vivre en France et le
deuxième sujet c'est le travail alors il
est tout à fait exact qu'à la campagne
il y a énormément d'entreprises par
exemple agricole
qui parfois la trouve chez des chez des
personnes qui viennent de l'étranger
notamment
les papiers et qui ne réussissent pas à
avoir les modes de transport qui leur
permettent de se déplacer pour venir
travailler à la campagne comme comme ils
disent ça c'est vrai mais
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse faire
d'affectation autoritaire ici ou là 5
ans après la vaguemico a pollué la
rentrée politique de la nupes avec les
affaires catenables et Bayou et
justement est-ce que désormais l'ex
secrétaire est justement est-ce que
désormais l'ex secrétaire national des
Verts Julien Bayou a raison de dire à
son île Rousseau à l'origine de la
médiatisation de son affaire qu'il ne
faut pas confondre féminisme et ma carte
isme
oui c'est au fond le même problème que
que j'évoquais à l'instant tous ceux qui
veulent que le débat se résume à des
luttes pour abattre l'adversaire ou le
concurrent y compris à l'intérieur du
même parti si j'ai bien compris
le les affirmations de madame
j'aime bien parce que vous essayez de
faire les réponses à ma place mais je
résisterai autant que je les ai et donc
et donc
oui je pense que que ce que c'est un
dévoiement de tout transformer en
affrontement irréductible de vouloir la
peau de celui qui n'est pas d'accord
avec vous même qu'il est même lorsqu'il
est dans le même parti alors vouloir la
peau de celui qui est pas d'accord avec
vous ça se voit si au niveau de la
justice le mieux de la justice Éric
Dupont-Moretti envoyer devant la Cour de
Justice de la République générale de
l'isée
Alexis Kohler est mise en examen l'un et
l'autre reste en place reste tenable et
puis je vais faire le parallèle avec ce
qui vous est arrivé il y a 5 ans vous
avez vous étiez mise à justice vous avez
été contraint la démission suite à votre
mise en cause mise en cause dans la mise
en examen dans l'enquête sur les
soupçons d'emploi fictifs d'assistant
parlementaires et de redéputer du MoDem
est-ce que vous voyez dans la manière
dont ce sont déroulés ces deux
des histoires entre guillemets une
injustice qui vous a énormément je n'ai
pas été contraint à la démission jamais
ouais vous avez démissionné je veux je
n'ai même pas démissionné
j'ai refusé de perdre un petit peu au
deuxième ouvert
et mon ami Marielle de Sarnez avait fait
la même chose
à laquelle aujourd'hui pourquoi
parce que j'ai jugé en mon âme est
conscience personnellement est-ce que
tout ça c'est des affaires personnelles
j'ai jugé que je ne pouvais pas exercer
mes fonctions dans la sérénité
nécessaire s'il y avait contre nous des
accusations aussi
scandaleuse et fausses est-ce que
évidemment
la situation n'est pas du tout la même
j'avais fait toute une grande partie de
ma de mon engagement politique sur le
thème de la moralisation de la vie
publique et il y avait besoin
et j'en étais chargé et vous voyez à
quel point c'était invivable que vous
soyez chargé de la moralisation et qu'on
vous attaque précisément en vous
imputant des attitudes
et des réalités le contraire la justice
est une autorité pas un pouvoir je ne
risque pas la justice de venir un
pouvoir céder Emmanuel Macron qui a
déclaré ça le 13 juillet 2021 on
conseille des mises après la mise en
examen d'Eric Dupond-Moretti est-ce que
vous faites partie de ceux qui
considèrent que les magistrats oublient
un peu trop que le rôle n'est pas d'être
un pouvoir mais voir un contre-pouvoir
et est-ce que vous faites partie de ceux
qui considèrent que les magistrats
règles un peu trop leur compte avec les
politiques
qui est des affrontements entre les la
magistrature et le pouvoir ça dure en
France depuis des siècles
et ça a été la cause ou une des causes
de l'effondrement de la monarchie
l'Ancien Régime donc c'est pas tout à
fait neuf mais Mitterrand disait faites
attention parce que ce type
d'affrontement a causé la mort de la
monarchie ça causera la mort de la
République disait-il je l'ai entendu de
mes propres oreilles dire ça
ma vision exactement la même je vais
vous dire la mienne pourquoi est-ce que
je pense que c'est une autorité et pas
un pouvoir parce qu'un pouvoir ça doit
être élu la légitimité d'un pouvoir
c'est ce que vous confie les citoyens il
se trouve que les magistrats ne sont pas
élus
qu'ils ont un fonctionnement interne et
que donc il ne peuvent pas être un
pouvoir ou alors on décide par exemple
de faire élire le procureur général de
la nation mais ça n'est pas la situation
et cette différence entre élu d'un côté
et chargé d'une autorité de l'autre elle
est fondamentale il nous reste une
minute et deux questions d'abord où on
est votre parcours judiciaire dans
l'affaire dans laquelle vous avez été
mis comme vous l'avez dit ça fait plus
de 5 ans et je répète que tout ceci est
faux tout ceci est faux dernière
question beaucoup pensent déjà 2027 au
sein même la majorité comme Édouard
Philippe Bruno maire général Darmanin on
dit que vous aussi vous y pensez 76 ans
vous aurez 76 ans 2027 est-ce que c'est
un point là je pourrais être candidat et
pour être président alors vous êtes
drôle parce que c'est ce genre de ce
genre de rumeurs là
émaille constamment le débat c'est très
simple je suis
et vous aussi un citoyen de plein
exercice est-ce que j'ai jamais renoncé
à exercer cette citoyenneté non donc des
candidats j'exercerai autant que je le
pourrais cette citoyenneté à tous les
dans toutes les rôles et toutes les
engagements qui font que la France la
société française peut choisir un destin
qui ressemblerait à ce que je crois donc
à ce que comme idéaliste si vous voulez
je veux bien être taxé d'idéalisme comme
idéaliste je crois je crois que la
France va mal je crois qu'elle pourrait
aller très bien et donc je ferai tout ce
que je peux dans toutes les échéances
donc y compris
des candidats à la présidentielle 2027
est-ce que vous voulez que je vous dise
vous pensez vous que les élections
présidentielles auront lieu en 2027 on
n'en sait rien
on ne sait pas ce qui peut se passer si
vous voyez aujourd'hui le le
l'incroyable difficulté des temps si
vous pensez qu'un zozo quelconque peut
dire 5 ans à l'avance ce qui va se
passer alors ne vous trompez pas tout ça
c'est
c'est des charlatans vous êtes prêts
toujours été prêt j'ai déjà été candidat
3 fois que ce que vous me racontez-nous
candidat et président pourquoi pas
vous voyez bien ce que vous cherchez
Mitterrand a succéder à un jeune
président vous pouvez succéder à un
jeune président ça peut tout à fait
arriver mais ça n'est pas ça la question
vous traitez de ces sujets pardon ne
prenez pas mal ce que je veux dire parce
qu'on arrive à traiter de ces sujets
dans ton léger pas du tout et moi pas
parce que peut-être je suis trop inquiet
mais ce que je vois venir et par sa
gravité telle que ça devrait mobiliser
toutes les forces disponibles toutes les
intelligences disponibles et toutes les
volontés disponibles c'est de ce côté là
que je suis de cette mobilisation je
vais dire de se réarmement moral j'ai
déjà utilisé l'expression dans
l'émission dans la France a le plus
grand besoin merci François Bayeux
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation bonne
fin d'après-midi sur